the court concludes that the term funds
as defined in article one of the icft
and as used in article two thereof
refers to resources provided or
collected for their monetary and
financial value and does not include the
means used to commit acts of terrorism
consequently the alleged supply of
weapons to various armed groups
operating in Ukraine and the alleged
organization of training for members of
those groups fall outside the material
scope of the
icft in the present case therefore only
monetary or financial resources es
provided or collected for use in
carrying out acts of terrorism May
provide the basis for the offense of
terrorism financing assuming that the
other elements of the offense referred
to in Article 2 paragraph 1 are also
present
the court recalls that in respect of its
claims under the icft Ukraine has
requested in addition to declaratory
relief the cessation by the Russian
Federation of ongoing violations
guarantees and assurances of
non-repetition compensation and moral
damages by the present judgment the
court declares that the Russian
Federation has violated its obligations
under article 9 paragraph 1 of the
icft and continues to be required under
that provision to undertake
investigations into sufficiently
substantiated allegations of Acts of
terrorism financing in eastern Ukraine
by the present judgment the court
declares that the Russian Federation has
violated its obligations under article
21A ofd and article 55
ofert it considers that the Russian
Federation remains under an obligation
to ensure that the system of instruction
in the Ukrainian language gives due
regard to the needs and reasonable
expectations of children and parents of
Ukrainian ethnic
origin the court does not find it
necessary or appropriate to order any
other remedy requested by
Ukraine